this is the 112th episode of money
ground and we want you to help us decide
what the next 112 episodes will be join
our MoneyGram patreon community and make
money ground with us
I was chosen to read the following
prompt
white Americans have way more advantages
than black Americans
I think I'm a rarity here
it would seem so do white Americans have
more advantages because they're white or
do just white Americans have advantages
because of historic factors I think that
people want to argue at the end of the
day over whether it's because you're
white or not I think that the answer is
because you're white in the past and
that's how it kind of carries over to
today you know even in times of the
United States history where black people
try to build wealth you know with the
Tulsa rights and everything where yeah
they that this wealth has been destroyed
and something that's upsetting to me is
when conservatives talk about how that
we can't blame the past what's happening
in the present that is true to some
extent but then the next breath they'll
talk about how important it is to have
dual parent households how important it
has it is to have a strong family to
have responsibility passed on from
parent to child and we've seen in the
past that because of racial issues that
process has been severely disrupted the
funny thing is is that agreeing with all
these things is when I did my research
when I was younger which arrived me to
my standpoint of being a conservative
because I believed it was racist
Democrat liberal ideologies and policies
dating all the way back to the 1800s all
the way up to the 1960s and then you the
purported big switch but I think it was
more so when Democrats decided to be a
bit more Cloak and Dagger about their
true opinions of black people and be
more secretive and more oh we want to
help you by you know doing these things
and seeing them as different things
affirmative action welfare all sorts of
ways they ruin our culture in places
where we are now so I want to get back
to the history of it because we're
talking I just want to make sure we're
clear giving them money hurt them right
is that what you're saying well yes
giving them because if your father's out
of the home that's when we give you the
money if you're living yes
and getting less than this amount of
time you're getting money
I don't even know what that means in
this scenario because yes
or wanted to exterminate the black race
because she thought they were weeds so
yeah we can literally talk about
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
that's what Margaret Sanger that's what
Democrat policies wanted to do to my
people so that's why I feel so strongly
about it because it is these policies
that date back centuries that were built
off of the death and Power of my people
let's take a breath so I'm breathing
okay so a lot of babies aren't but I am
seven I don't know what that means when
I say Thriller baby out with the
bathwater you want to completely get rid
of welfare okay or at least the concern
I don't want to put that on you you
haven't said that but the conservative
apparatus does clearly so giving money
to a group of people
does not hurt them I mean you're talking
about a lottery you can literally take
money but they're there's
been millions make them all millionaires
I don't care giving money to black
people does not hurt them and that that
has not happened though that has not
happened what do you mean that has not
happened giving it it hasn't been
arrested
off of the idea of hey we get these
families split up we get these so then
let them keep the family together and
keep all the money I mean I guess so but
I guarantee you I guess so why would you
not advocate for that so in your I guess
research of like history of this country
and everything
um do you find like the Reconstruction
Era and like the failures of like what
it wanted to be and then what it ended
up being
um and then which led into you know
which you know had Downstream effects to
enter into the Jim Crow era and you know
you have policies like redlining that
influence you know how schools are
funded the downstream effects of slavery
do you think
um
put black people as
generally in a worse off position than a
white American I think Generation by
generation the effects of slavery have
been diluted but Generation by
generation the effects of racism welfare
based policies and things of that nature
became even more great so in the 1880s
or so when we had our first black
members of Congress which were indeed
Republicans I think that was a great
start for things but obviously we had
terrible things that happened like the
Tulsa Massacre uh among you know black
people being chased out of their homes
by the KKK sure all funded by the
Democrat Party All supported by the
Democrats I I mean I need to stop you
there uh can you attribute not to the
party but to the ideology because I
think when you think regardless of what
whatever the party switch was
traditionally conservative values did
not like that's more aligned with
um you know uh uh more racist policies
2020 is conservatism to 1880s
conservatism
oh I was loving the one before
so personally I feel like there's really
only one thing that white people have a
true advantage over black people with
and it's that white people are less
likely to be forced into a box it
happens with black people onto other
black people but it especially happens
with white liberals onto black
conservatives where we are told that we
are supposed to think a certain way be a
certain way and if we're not then we're
called all these names like
Etc and the worst of all is Bootlegger
because I hate when a white liberal
tells me as a black man that I'm a boot
licker because then I asked who's boot
am I licking because you're telling me
as a white person that me as a black
person that I'm licking your boot
because I don't think in this box that
you want me to frame my mentality in
that to me is real racism and that's
what we need to stop allowing to happen
to us because black people are so quick
now to not Branch out and to have new
ways of thinking or to go into careers
like Agriculture and these other career
paths that black people don't typically
get into it's not because of racism
stopping them from getting in there it's
because we're told for so long that you
have to follow this path and you have to
think a certain way I think America is a
great place for for a black person I
think I'm an American anything that's
available to you is available to me and
mine I've personally never experienced
white people having way more privileges
than me like I'm sure you could find
certain institutions where black people
are treated differently but in general I
don't think that I've missed out on
anything because of being black and if
anything it's given me more of a voice
because people will want to hear what I
say now because I'm black so if anything
it I have more of a platform now just on
the basis of being a black conservative
and saying what's not popular than I
would if I was just a white person who
was also conservative
Court's decision
intended affirmative action
I think
I'm not going to start someone else get
started sorry I think affirmative action
has served its purpose I think that it
was necessary for a particular time and
I think that every black person knows
how to get into college everybody I mean
you could pull out the the names the
Oprah the oh President Obama you can
pull out the the head of Time Warner was
black man but Forbes was black man we
know what to do now we don't need
affirmative action anymore and to me
affirmative action is offensive
sometimes especially nowadays because
um I have six children and two boys four
girls
and all of them went to Harvard and
Columbia and this one and that one and
it would it breaks my heart to think
that they uh accomplished their that
goal of getting to into these
institutions just because of the color
of their skin I can definitely say that
it creates a lot of tension when you
have affirmative action I remember my
first week at the University of Illinois
I was sitting with some classmates and a
white student turned to me and jokingly
like hey Xavier like did you just attach
a smiley face when you applied for this
college and I started asking what he
meant and he said to me that he was like
you're black I'm assuming you had decent
grades you could have just attached a
smiley face and you would have gotten
into the university so I was livid by
that and I went off I started naming all
my accomplishments and I felt so
confident only for about an hour because
then an hour later I started saying to
myself like wow like did I actually earn
my way in here I started to have this
insecurity and I started wondering to
myself did I earn this position myself
or did my ancestors suffering earn this
for me and two I've seen it in the a
sense of like affirmative action taking
away from other people who are
minorities like I had a friend who was
Asian and he in high school and he
really wanted to go to MIT that was his
dream school he interned there he was
super like prepared to go there and he
didn't get in and you can only assume
that it was because of affirmative
action because they have such a large
Asian population that they want to admit
other people
um yeah I was going to actually argue
that it's more racist nowadays because
it excludes so many Asian Americans from
getting into universities who do deserve
a spot and they can't get in because of
affirmative affirmative action which
again like you were saying was necessary
at the time but now it's like anybody if
you have the skills to do it and you're
in America you can't you can get in I
don't think affirmative action is the
worst thing considering all the
different types or aspects of a
background you might take into account
when somebody's getting into college
whether they were in certain clubs you
know Boy Scouts what type of classes
they took that might not be available to
everybody I don't think that factoring
in the affirmative action is necessarily
a bad thing but I feel like because of
everything you guys have said the Optics
behind it are so horrible today that
even if it is slightly beneficial in the
long run for certain people I think we
can probably refocus most of that into
figuring out like the class that people
come from the neighborhoods the
backgrounds or whatever without it
having to necessarily Target race the
only thing that I kind of Wonder now
that it's gone is instead of a black
person being in school thinking like man
am I here because I'm an affirmative
action pick is it going to be a kid that
is poor or a kid that's from a different
zip code we should do away with all of
it it's just like submit an application
no demographics why do they ask your
sexuality like why do they ask all that
so if affirmative action accomplished
its purpose why do we still see the
disparities that we do in the
professional workplace if you average
white wealth and compare it to Blackwell
totals
white people as a whole have about 50
times greater wealth than black people
as a whole uh per capita so I just don't
understand why you think affirmative
action has accomplished its purpose I
don't serious why do you assume that
just because there is a disparity means
it's because of a racial issue what else
would it be from I mean upbringing
economic abilities desire to go desire
to I mean it does play a lot if you grow
up in a neighborhood that experiences a
lot of trauma you're not as likely to do
as well in school which means why did
they grow up in a neighborhood that
experiences a lot of trauma I mean lots
of people do yes but why specifically do
more black people
government assistance programs
government assistance programs like what
shark redlining I mean you can go into
that if you'd like to but let's take a
look at the great societies act which
was created to kick black fathers out of
the home and get black mothers on
welfare assistance these things aren't
beneficial for economics these things
aren't beneficial for actually Paving a
way for success for black children and
black families I mean taking you know
reducing a two-family household to a
one-family household isn't going to make
them the richest man in the world it
isn't even going to get them out of high
school nonetheless maybe the ability to
get to College the child yes but a
two-parent household in comparison to a
one-parent household that's how it is
not going to be nearly as successful
that child is more disposed to being
sent into prison by doing crimes or not
doing very well in school so how are
they even supposed to get that you know
that wealth disparity shrunk if they
aren't even able to get out of the
community that is causing these problems
for them something I think that this
conversation illustrates is that like
affirmative action is literally the very
end of the line of a lot of different
parts of a person's life and by that
point trying to rectify all of the
inequities that have existed to try to
remedy any of that at the very they end
with affirmative action it might just be
too broad a brush and maybe we'd be
better served focusing on the earlier
issues than trying to throw a kid who
maybe you know can barely read at a
sixth grade level into a college to hope
that that's the thing that fixes the
problem at the end of the line I think
affirmative action wasn't really
supposed to like send kids to Harvard
that weren't prepared to go to Harvard I
think that's quite a myth in fact I
think those that have the qualities to
get to Harvard
were before Improvement action work
could just completely overlooked you
know I Clarence Thomas is like the
perfect example
um you know regardless of what you uh
think about him
um he was able to get to Harvard because
of affirmative action because you know
it was it focused on
um finding people that were again like
just overlooked but things it ended up
changing it morphed into something else
so what started out as a good program
from of giving all black people or
people
um with a lesser chance or less
opportunity it started out as that and
then it morphed it and I'm not sure who
morphed it but it morphed into okay so
now we have to have one black one
Hispanic one this one that's how that
works but hey talk to the corporations
talk to the people who hire talk to the
board members who say we need to have a
woman on a board we need to have a black
on the board we need to have a Latina a
latinx whatever on the board so so it
morphed from from helping us into now
tokenization yes so you have to have one
of this one well when you start with a
country where people only hire you if
you're white that's necessary and I know
that you said that it started good and
then ended whatever and I don't think
that affirmative action was perfect by
any measure but we still see really
really bad inequality so if you're going
to get rid of affirmative action what's
the replacement meritocracy is people
need to there's no meritocracy in this
country if you look at Elon Musk he's
destroying Twitter there's no air
meritocracy that's ridiculous well first
thing I want to bounce back to is it's
not a myth that there are like
minorities that are being put into
colleges that they're not ready for if
you look at a lot of these top
universities including Harvard Yale Etc
you're going to see a lot of minorities
on academic probation because they are
being placed in universities that they
are not ready for they are not cut out
for that just yet and it even just makes
sense if you look at how much they have
to achieve in order to get there Asian
students on average have to score 450
points higher than a black student in
order to get in the same University so
if you think of the universities that
have courses Etc that that great on a
curve you can only have so many people
with an A so many people with a B Etc so
that means that the bottom percentile is
going to fail who is most likely just
based on logic going to be the ones
failing it's going to be the people who
didn't have the credentials to get there
in the first place and then I have to
bounce back to I want to I want to get I
want to get you on that point because I
would pause it that the people who are
least likely to have good outcomes in an
academic setting are those who have to
work two jobs are those who have to
drive there from home because they can't
afford a dorm are those who have to go
into crippling financial debt these are
the and have other stresses in their
life they can't afford a doctor they
can't afford a dentist they can't afford
anything so those are the things it's
not just black people it's not just but
it's overwhelming with numbers there are
more white people in poverty than black
people if you look at the wrong numbers
but if you actually I don't understand
poverty in general though I don't think
it's like who's in poverty it's like
poverty sucks maybe we should make
college free and maybe we want to have
if you have an action wouldn't be that
necessary it'll get even more ghetto
if you have a program that says you are
under if you are under a certain income
level this is how we'll help you that
will overwhelmingly help black people at
a far greater percentage and it will
help white people
Trump supports black lives
I think that President Trump supports
all lives I think that he looks at all
American citizens as equal I don't see
him doing anything that would make you
feel like he does not support black
lives that's of course going to lead
into the conversation of black lives
matter which was a movement and an
organization with so much corruption
Donald Trump not supporting that
organization doesn't mean that he
doesn't support black lives it just
means that he doesn't support the
fraudulent organization that's stealing
so much money from so many people to do
absolutely nothing with it nor does he
support a destructive movement that is
destroying cities communities lives Etc
so I don't see why someone would think
that President Trump doesn't support
black lives
I've heard him say he knows all the best
black people he has all the best black
friends I I do support black people all
the time uh so sorry that was a very bad
impression but
um I don't think that I don't think
Donald Trump wants bad things to happen
to black people so in that respect I
think he does support black lives but
the other side of that is he's not
really doing anything he didn't do
anything as president certainly to
uplift black people the economy affects
black people yeah I certainly disagree
with that point one of the biggest
things
we'll get into that one later one of the
biggest things he did is he secured
permanent funding for hbcus one of the
largest increases we ever saw for hbcus
personally done by his administration
among many other things the first step
act which you know there's a lot of
debate about whether it was really the
best thing to do but that was definitely
a A Kiss of love to black to the black
race freeing Alice Johnson for menial
drug crimes she committed in the past
that had her locked up she did not get
to see her family for years
yeah but that's not like okay I did say
I agree but I agree in the sense that
Donald Trump doesn't literally want bad
things to happen to black people like I
think a lot of conservatives do so I
think that he just says the most part
yeah I do think that I think uh the mo
he says the things that will get him
elected so I don't think that he has any
personal grudges against uh certain you
know most people uh he just says the
most popular thing so I I think like Ron
DeSantis would be yeah run to Santos
would be somebody that I think actually
wants black people to be hurt so by that
standard yeah Donald Trump supports
black lives by Leaps and Bounds you
think Donald Trump says the most popular
thing yeah really yes and why do so many
people hate him he got elected as
president yes he did yeah he didn't win
the popular vote
neither time that's a liberal trust
that's a liberal talking I'm helping you
here I I'm trying to see the logic in
this obviously he says things to be to
be elected as a politician very
similarly to how Joe Biden did except
Joe Biden actually has a history of
racism if he said things that people
didn't like he wouldn't have been our
president so you like everything that
Donald Trump says you think everything
he says is popular I love a lot of the
things he says I think he's hilarious
when he said big water that was one of
my favorite quotes big water water big
water ocean water
he has the funniest one-liners so I love
a lot of the things he says as far as
policy sucks but I'm just Dr wearing a
hunter Biden hat he likes a different
kind of one line oh he's I I know
conservatives love talking about us it's
different Coke
Trump is less of the issue and more so
the people that support him like die
hard they facilitate that kind of like
hate I think for a lot of people not
just black people but like I mean this
man took out like a full page in a
newspaper calling for the public
execution of five black kids his hotels
all of his businesses have rampant uh
history of denying black people
apartments or whatever so I forgot about
that
look I mean Donald Trump cares about
Donald Trump
um so I don't think he really cares
about anyone I guess unless you're like
super rich or whatever when you look at
his history on racial issues whether
it's the country's comment the
plethora of comments he made about
Mexican people
um I just the comments he's been about
Muslims the idea that Trump cares at all
about some particular racial minority
and it gets a little bit silly I think
Trump will say whatever he needs to say
to rile up his base and get elected I
don't necessarily think those statements
come from a place of hatred I don't
think he was ever saying specifically oh
if if you pray five times a day towards
the east or towards Mega based on
wherever you are you're a bad person I
think he was saying if you like to fly
planes into Towers or behead people or
throw people off of buildings maybe
you're not the most virtuous person out
there I I supported Trump because
um all he he made all of the he made the
economy good and so the economy then
impacted black people white people
Latino people it impacted everybody but
Trump he did things specifically I don't
think about black people he thought
about himself and he thought about how
can I make America great for me and and
making them and and I thought you know
what I'ma go with this guy and the
reason I'm gonna go with this guy is
because if he can make America great for
and he can make that rise for everybody
I'm going to benefit from that so that's
why I went and that's why I voted for
him that's why I supported him how does
that specifically benefit black people
again he has he's a businessman but he's
also a racist businessman like well
documented so so like I just
and Biden's not
Biden's not yes he is he created the
crime bill so that's but that's that's
regardless of Central Park five that's
what you brought up right how do you
feel about that okay so you wanted them
to be killed well executed just because
they were black
and he he
bars people from attending his
businesses or like renting apartments
from all his like stupid Trump Towers I
just like I think Trump at that point
was like many people in this room
particularly liberals a victim of the
media I think he was scared I think he
was ashamed of the things that he heard
in the news and wanted to take action
himself as a businessman why are you
infantilizing him I also I don't like
also real quick because people keep
bringing up this comparison to the 93
crime bill from Biden that crime bill
this was at the height of like violent
crime in the crack epidemic in the
United States the Congressional Black
Caucus supported that crime belt
everybody in the United States supported
that crime Bill the idea that that crime
bill was like some racist piece of
legislation that Biden's just Wheeling
out because he hates black people and
that's somehow comparable to the the
Donald Trump's treatment of the Central
Park five that were already exonerated
that that wasn't a victim of the media
the media said they were they were done
they were exonerated in court they
weren't there the prosecutor of the of
the the five they actually he was a
black guy and so in being a black guy he
went in he looked at all the evidence
and said these guys are guilty black
people can also be racist against other
blacks or let's make mistakes
so if anybody does anything you disagree
with in regards to the Central Park five
even if they themselves are a black
person then oh they're just a
self-loathing black person they're just
a racist black person
doing his job
that's that's my policy if they disagree
with me they're racist I think Trump I
think Trump has shown a his history of
or Behavior I did I did vote for him or
Hillary because I just don't see him as
a conservative hero I don't even think
he's a conservative very conservative I
voted Trump in 2016. just so you all
know so I'm just saying so I need to exp
I need you to elaborate on if people
disagree with you they're racist just in
general I was just he's just yeah
sorry if I triggered you I'm sorry you
made a point a couple minutes back where
you said um he just kind of says these
things to rile up his base
um why does he need to do that at the
expense of black people then he doesn't
do that at the I am a member of his base
and I'm sitting there like oh man this
is amazing
and I don't know you can call me so call
me so you're saying you're calling for
the public execution of five black men
that were exonerated during the campaign
Trail he didn't do that when he was a
policeman again it's everything in New
York it's everything Steve said about
the comments about Muslims the comments
about uh Mexican immigrants number about
Mexican immigrants never about Muslims
about terrorists and about criminals and
rapists I these are very important
delineations to make and if you believe
I think you understand oh I think it's
an immigrants I think it's more of you
being oh man oh these poor Mexicans they
need to be supported it's more of that
savior complex wow behind acting or
trying to act DACA where those these
people were registered with the federal
government they were in school they were
doing everything that they needed to do
they had no home elsewhere they were
brought into this country as minors like
what's the explanation I think that
requires more Nuance like I mentioned
before their education I think there
were some people feeding him bad policy
advice thinking oh this will be really
good for your base and he's doing a lot
that's okay that's okay if we feel that
way so if so if I so if I take
responsibility for something if I say he
has responsibility for something well
then you're right but if I'm saying well
maybe there's some people around him
advising him falsely it's infantilized
he was the president there's no good way
he called the shots what are you talking
about the only path forward to solving
illegal immigration starts with amnesty
for everybody here the reality is
there's some 10 to 15 million illegal
immigrants here we're not deporting them
all with the people who are already here
it that's a lot more of a messy nuanced
conversation
um but as far as people coming in I do
think we need stronger borders and
actual like vetting happening and I just
want to say
um in Ronald Reagan's day he was given
the promise he was he said look if if
you go ahead and you pass this
particular Bill we'll give these people
amnesty and we're done and it didn't
happen we didn't uh illegal immigration
continued even after Reagan already said
we would give these people amnesty
so that's why we get to burn up our butt
because
um he had already done it hopefully the
devil is giving him amnesty true that's
terrible no that's no that's base thank
you tasteless
Ninth Circle baby
my political beliefs have changed from
the past
I grew up in a conservative household
actually in Ohio and my parents were
always pretty political so I'm I always
stayed political I was very religious as
a teenager uh sometime during college
and then afterwards especially during
covet my sister actually indoctrinated
me into a more leftist position and I
overcorrected a little bit I started
becoming pretty cringy as far as like
you know sit down and let you know let
the minorities all talk right don't say
anything don't speak over them Etc they
would you know it was like the whole you
can't speak over Candace Owens even if
she's literally a Nazi kind of thing so
um I I stand by that so um yeah I kind
of leveled out thankfully and I'm less
cringe now did you are you I cringed
this is level now imagine if we would
have been here a year ago yeah I mean
maybe maybe I am being cringe who cares
I
um so I grew up conservative but I did
have more left-leaning ideas about like
black lives matter and critical race
Theory and I was kind of I was watching
a lot of you YouTube and you know I did
agree that black people were oppressed
and all of these different things and
that we were kind of got the short end
of the stick and um during 2020 when
there was you know everything crazy was
happening and I started uh organizing
rallies against uh the mandates because
I thought that they were just totally
unconstitutional and Un-American and
then George Floyd dies and initially I
was like enraged like everybody else and
then it started to become this weird
like
um political like agenda masquerading or
behind his face like it just the face of
what was actually happening started to
peel off and I was like oh I mean I
would counter protest BLM activists at
My Town Square when I lived in Texas and
they were some of the most just bitter
vile horrible people you could ever meet
meanwhile like the Confederate group
that would protest there against them
also they were like the nicest people
ever to me ironically I grew up in a Dem
in a democratic not a democratic
household but kind of a political but
everybody was Democrat and then I I got
a job and when I got a job and I saw all
the taxes come out and I started looking
to the left and to the right and going
oh my money's whittling away over here
and I said you know what after Reagan
I'm just going to go ahead and declare
myself a Republican and I've been a
republican ever since my mom is pretty
liberal my she married my stepdad when I
was like 15 16 in high school and he was
super conservative like love Trump Die
Hard Trump fan and they had a lot of
like back and forth hearing the two
sides like people who are on such Polar
Opposites just like argue all the time
about stuff seeing that there's a lot of
similarities in both sides like the far
radical left and the far radical right
they have a lot of similarities they
just don't want to come and like see it
I started off actually kind of similar
to you I went to a Jesuit High School I
grew up very conservative my mom is
Cuban so ride or die Bush supporter who
is now a ride or die Trump supporter I
think the point in my life when I was
the most like libertarian was probably
the lowest point in my life financially
and I think it's because some of the
conservatives do really well is they
make you feel like you can always like
succeed as long as you you work hard
enough now something that progresses in
liberals suck at that you're a victim of
systemic racism your blacks are going to
be discriminated against you're a woman
so nobody's going to care about your
feelings et cetera et cetera et cetera
whereas Republicans will tell you listen
if you work hard you can do whatever you
want like just as long as you're willing
to put in the work and I felt that way
up to the moment where I was losing my
house where I had an ex-girlfriend that
was pregnant where I had been fired from
my previous job there was a whole bunch
of horrible stuff going on in my life
and I very very luckily got into online
content creation and from there as I
started to make more money I started to
pay more taxes when I get older and I
look at taxes that come out of my
paycheck
um I just I mean I care a little bit but
it was just so funny to me that back
when I was making fifteen twenty
thousand a year I'm like I gotta vote
for the lower tax bracket blah blah blah
like I'm barely paying any tax anyways
and you know now that I'm older like if
the government wants to take you know a
few you know 10 20 whatever have any
more thousand dollars out
I did but I got very very lucky doing so
very lucky
luck it's not just luck but the
difference is that born into a wealthier
family you can make so many more
mistakes in life and when you're born
poor you get like one or two before your
life is over and that's really sad to me
yeah so I used to be a liberal I voted
for Bernie Sanders in 2016 as much as I
regret that now my family was pretty
left-wing some of the people in my
family were like radically left like
would refer to white people as blue-eyed
redheaded Devils things of that nature
and as I got older I actually started
being really outspoken for BLM I was
supposed to be on a reality show
teaching people how to be a BLM activist
at the time I did a deep dive on BLM and
I started to realize all of these lies
so then I took a step back I'm like okay
what else am I being lied to about and I
started looking at the Democratic party
and questioning my own loyalty to being
on the left I personally think both
sides tend to be racist in different
ways I don't think the government is on
the side of the people in general and
that's just me being you know a radical
when I was young I used to jump for joy
and say oh yeah Obama black president
that's so amazing he's the same color as
me but when I started do more research
one of the biggest things I was confused
about is well why is he a Democrat what
is a Democrat I did more research about
the Democrat Party and sure you guys are
going to pop off about the head saying
oh there's a party switch in the
southern strategy and all these things
which is true which you may say is true
I don't believe it is true at all I
understand you know you may think I'm
wrong however one of the biggest
questions I had was why is Obama in the
same party as the people that started
the KKK the same people that voted
against the Civil Rights Act the same
people that are on the news talking
about how black people aren't able to
accomplish anything and need to be on
welfare and need to be promoted uh with
affirmative action and things of that
nature I also as in terms of I guess of
my political Journey
um I was raised conservative actually
um and then High School became I guess
sort of a political uh and then
throughout college and I guess just
throughout my life since then
um I think I've I guess even call me
Progressive you can call me you know
socialist whatever you um but
um I guess that's I guess in the area of
where I fall um you said that you were
um Bernie fan in 2016 and then you
transitioned to being I guess more
conservative
um
I guess I don't know to me Bernie
Sanders
um from what he said to what you think
now what was the the shift
um for me with socialism because back
then I was a very broke college kid and
I just had this mentality that
everything should be free and I was
feeling a bit entitled like everything
should be handed to me because I was
black because I was very much in that
mentality as I learned more about free
markets as I learned more about
capitalism I started to appreciate that
much more I started to appreciate small
business much more limited government
low regulations I just started to like
that much more but I would say just more
when it comes to economics I don't agree
with him reparations are necessary
when we talk about reparations I think
that doing reparations in the way that a
lot of people think of it where we just
give it to black people I'm not an
expert on this but I think it would be
more income based in that in itself like
I said earlier uh would uh
disproportionately benefit black people
because if you recognize that they are
disproportionately affected
by a systemic Injustice than doing it on
like a class level would uplift
proportionally more black people than
white people or any other races yeah I
think like
um
mostly like black GIS that were left out
of like the new deal for instance
um that to be able to come back and um
as a white American as a white veteran
to get a home loan and then build that
generational wealth
um you could not get that as a black
American
um so
there needs to be I think reparations I
don't care really what form it comes
from I think free healthcare uh free
college so that everyone has like an
equal opportunity to
um uh to educate themselves to Build a
Better Lives for themselves
um so it's sort of like uh
and I think Germany is also a perfect
model to follow
um you know by uh don't issuing first of
all a formal apology uh which we haven't
even done that
um but also just like donating to like
different uh funds and you know just I
think a more Equitable Society striving
for that is uh reparations in himself
I have no problems with reparations if
they had happened initially during this
like slavery or the civil rights
movement or any of that but to try and
do that now logistically it just doesn't
really make any sense and like where
would this money come from like we're in
so much debt as a nation when I get this
money I'm biracial or tri-racial like do
mixed people get it and like do Irish
people get reparations when they were
indentured servants I think for
reparations if you can find specific
instances of somebody being like
actually deprived of something whether
specific instances of like the 40 acres
of a meal process uh promise or whether
you can find specific entrance uh cases
of like Chinese people building
railroads or Irish people whatever
people being deprived of things that's
okay but otherwise yeah it's a
logistical nightmare there's no possible
way that we'd be able to do it well yeah
America is unique because we have bent
over backwards for decades now putting
minorities in a position of privilege I
feel like we have done so much to give
back to the communities that were
obviously wronged and I agree with both
of you like had this happened a long
time ago I would understand it if we had
specific incidences that we could trace
where people were just completely
screwed over I would respect it but
right now I don't deserve a payment for
something my great great great
grandparents went through and I don't
think that white people are responsible
for paying that to me either I know we
don't use the Verge the word Virtue
signaling but it's sort of like a bribe
for a vote in a way at least in my
opinion in States like California where
they've been throwing around the idea of
oh we want to pay out this much money to
every black Citizen in there in this
state it's like are you serious because
this is kind of like a joke in my
opinion I think that if you if we impose
or yeah impose reparations now I think
it would rip America apart I think that
we're already separated enough as it is
and now you're going to have people
walking around going you owe me money
you owe me I'm not paying you any money
it would just really rip us apart giving
somebody money doesn't mean anything if
they don't know what to do with the
money or how to handle the money so if
the primary issue in Black Culture or
with black people is generational trauma
then maybe they need more therapy than
they need money honestly which
conservatives are also against well
that's kind of my heart like if there is
like that like generational trauma or
whatever like I think
examples of like free healthcare um they
could see a therapist and not be you
know fall into debt and I think the
argument of like the logistical
nightmares of it I think if we want to
pay for something in this country we
usually find a way to do it especially
when it comes to the military so um I
mean we pay for multi-billion dollars
and it's who's supposed to get them not
to attack progressors but that is like
the most Progressive idea in the world
is like I can see the headlines like
reparations voted on in Congress to be
paid in the form of free therapy for
people in the hood that just sounds like
the funniest thing in the world but well
I also don't think it's going to come
directly from like you know white person
to black person like oh you you
um your lineage uh affected his lineage
it is though like in San Francisco they
were going to raise the average family
or the average household in San
Francisco was expected to pay six
hundred thousand dollars each with the
five million dollar per black person
proposal that they had and I used to
live in the San Francisco Bay area and I
was repulsed by that because you have so
many homeless veterans on this streets
and they were going to give black people
a home for as little as one dollar just
for being black mind you slavery wasn't
even in California so why that was going
to be the case like I don't understand
but it's extremely unrealistic to think
that the average family in San Francisco
can afford that because Newsome wants to
get reelected okay but you don't really
care about homeless veterans right right
you don't know like you're all your
arguments
conservative so so what policies do you
support for homeless veterans there's
ways to address I mean specifically for
homeless in general that's a whole
different conversation okay let's say
that we didn't find a middle ground in
there yeah all right but that's a great
ending note white liberals have a savior
complex
foreign
well I gotta say this is a shock I never
expected all four of you to just come
forward and admit it but you know what
I'm happy with these results I just
think it's uh a lot of people a lot of I
guess uh people you know of the left
whatever
um can kind of fall into that trap of uh
thinking that you know black people as a
monolith need to be saved as like as a
whole I have no shame about it I have a
savior complex as an older brother and I
will save you whether you like it or not
so that's just me well it's definitely
not because a lot of us are really just
exhausted of being viewed as our skin
color because when you have this mindset
that you need to save black people and
we're just sitting here minding our own
business and living Our Lives the way we
want to I don't know why it is that
people feel this immense pressure to be
so apologetic and just always trying to
cater and coddle to black people when we
just want to be treated like everybody
else we're equal for a reason I think
especially recently with a lot of Riot
stuff that's gone on or protest stuff
that's gone on people on the left tend
to infantilize a lot of different types
of protests and especially even talking
to you know some of the other black
content creators I do content with when
you hear a lot of progressives come out
and say well they don't have a choice
but to Riot or break into the store or
while they're stealing you know these
Electronics or shoes for good reasons
you just don't realize it I think a lot
of people kind of look both ways and
it's a little bit weird that there's
such a complex on the left to excuse
like every single possible negative
behavior from somebody as long as
they're a skin color that you're kind of
in charge of protecting I find that very
offensive yeah I find it extremely
it upsets me um to hear that because
um we're just like you we just have a
different skin color and to hear that
you have to you have to help me is
offensive to me I can do my I can do it
on my own well we have to break down
sometimes why these riots happen you
know MLK once said that riots are the
voice of the unheard so if you are to
address the problem and stop the riots
you have to address the underlying
inequality that has historically been
pervasive you know even if you as
individual people are doing fine and you
don't want anybody else to get in the
way of that that's cool and I'm not
going to get it I'm I'm not going to be
the one to get in the way but the
disparities are undeniable so if you
take pride in having like a white savior
complex what is it that you think that
you're doing to save black people and
what is it that you think that you're
saving black people from I am trying to
make the world a better place through
whatever means I can and but you're
doing it on the backs of us
I actually do I feel like like you want
to be a savior for and you're using me
to make yourself feel good that's that's
what how am I hurting you you're but
you're not letting me have my own voice
you're not letting me how you're
speaking now yeah you're cutting it off
yeah well I feel like I have to yeah
well what's happening I mean you're
speaking right now you're speaking right
now in this particular setting but what
you're saying is like um you you took it
back to riots and so forth and it makes
it seem like the only way that we as
black people can voice our have a voice
is by rights and then you need to come
along and you need to the okay poor
little black child let me help you let
me help you that's offensive to me and
and I feel like you're making yourself
feel good about trying to tame help us
in it I also think that like when we
talk about damage I think especially
when it comes to a lot of the
shoplifting stuff that's going on in
certain cities you get a lot of white
people that live in nice suburbs saying
things like shoplifting is no big deal
that's fine and then you'll catch
YouTube videos of them later on being in
a Walgreens in like a shoddy
neighborhood like man why is the
deodorant behind a locked case it's very
easy to sit behind a gated community and
say oh well you know it's not a big deal
you know they they steal because they
have to riots are the language of the
unheard I think people haven't read the
full context of that quote when MLK was
saying rise to the language of the
unheard you need to address the
underlying condition he wasn't condoning
the writing he was just understanding it
obviously there are a bunch of white
people that feel they need to be a
savior but I think there's a difference
between helping and saving like I don't
think I'll need to save black people but
I would tremendously love to help and
make sure everyone has like uh equal
outcome or not equal outcome but at
least equal opportunity which in my
opinion I feel we do not have in this
country
this is awkward
hi guys
um so I didn't step forward just because
I don't want to Broad brush all white
liberals as having a white savior
complex I have experienced white
liberals who do have that and
um they're very unpleasant people but I
don't think every single white person
who's a liberal or who is an activist
for BLM or any of those things
necessarily has a white savior complex I
think that there's a lot of white people
who genuinely think that black people
are oppressed and they want to help and
that's what they're told what it seems
like to me when most people have save
your complex regardless of who whom
they're trying to save it's like they're
taking real pain and real trauma and
using that as a way to push this
political agenda but also to alleviate
themselves of whatever guilt that they
feel unnecessarily like I don't know why
a white person today would feel guilty
for things that happened decades ago let
alone something that happened centuries
ago I've never seen a white person say I
personally feel guilty for slavery maybe
they're out there but I've never heard
that yeah in second grade when they
taught us about slavery almost every kid
in my classroom would spend their entire
time looking at black kids in that
classroom how was I supposed to not
think wow these people are feeling
guilty for something that they have no
involvement in and I have no every kid
in my classroom understood the context
people hate feeling uncomfortable and
obviously you don't want to feel like
the bad guy on so they I feel like it
comes from a place of like oh well like
let me make sure that I'm Different like
I'm showing you that I want to like help
you but it comes across like I think it
can land very poorly I'll tell you what
stop it stop it because what happens is
when you put yourself as the white
savior what you do is you elevate
yourself above the black person because
you feel then like you have to save us
so just stop it just treat everybody
regular normal just like if just like I
would treat you regular normal you treat
us regular normal rather than trying to
save us I just got one thing I wanted to
bring up earlier about taxes because you
were saying that you don't you you had
your job and you were talking about how
like you get the tax every every time
and you're like seeing your tax go up I
worked in nursing homes in 2020 covid
the last thing that was on my mind when
I watched 60 and 70 year olds on their
Death Beds suffocating to death was
taxes
I was worried about health care I didn't
give a about taxes in that time
so when I go to work every day that's
what I see that's what I want to fix
I see I see you once again elevating
yourself above the rest of us and
particularly at me a white man elevating
himself above a black person
I'm sorry I'm sorry
that we're all Americans and because
we're all Americans we and actually we
we know that America has a bunch of
problems and I think every person here
wants to solve the problems and I think
everybody is bringing what they have to
the table with their ideas on how to get
us to unify this kind of stuff and right
but you got something in there hopefully
I mean I'm going to give you the benefit
benefit of the doubt that you have
something in there that's redeeming
about you that would bring all of
Americans together so I hope that we end
on the note of American
you and i t y i I would like to say
we're all made in the image of God and
so we're all have art and errant worth
just because we're Made In His Image and
we should treat each other as fellow
image bearers not just by the color of
our skin I mean that's Martin Luther
King said he also did not like
capitalism
I think something that's really
challenging um I've definitely been
guilty in the past of throwing around
the Uncle Tom word I used to be hardcore
Progressive I'm still relatively
Progressive but something that I've
learned as time has gone on is being a
white person isolates you from a lot of
the different types of racial struggles
that people go through and those
struggles can take a lot of different
forms not just you know was my ancestor
a slave and not just is my culture bad
but sometimes in the way that you know
people grow and develop right like am I
actually choosing these political
beliefs because they mean something to
me or is it because I'm black or my
parents are black if I speak a certain
way am I betraying my race if I am a
political orientation am I a bootlegger
and I think that it's important when
you're coming from a progressive point
of view to understand that even though
there are conservatives that are black
people it's you have to treat them as
individuals and not just come at it with
this like you're black you're
conservative therefore here's like six
or seven different slurs that I can use
against you but they're approved because
it happens again the progressive side